en france un petit garçon de 5 ans est
mort cette nuit à bussang dans les
vosges la maison il dormait avec sa
petite soeur et sa grand mère a été
éventrée par une coulée de boue la
situation reste particulièrement
préoccupante pour toute la région
dans les vosges la meurthe et moselle
haute marne la haute saône aura de
nombreuses routes et des voies ferrées
ont été fermées en guérit ce fut violent
et soudain la coulée de boue a dévalé la
montagne pour s'abattre là sur une
maison construite à flanc de roche les
murs du premier étage n'ont pas résisté
un enfant de 5 ans est mort enseveli les
autres membres de la famille une petite
fille et deux personnes âgées ont pu
s'échapper à temps
la voisine a été découvert deux bouts
d'autant bas était pieds nus dans la
neige pour lui rappeler aux secours
c'est l'enfer est à l'origine de cet
enfer la pluie l'eau des trombes d'eau
qui ont envahi les vosges
ici à servair donne l'eau est reparti
comme elle est venue très vite
maintenant il faut nettoyer vidanger
écopé dans la région on sait faire les
crues sont un grand classique mais tout
de même l'habitude de l'isolation de
plus en plus vite les fleuves qui
déborde les rivières et les cours d'eau
qui enfle il a fallu couper les routes
dans l'est du pays
parfois même on a dû fermer les voies
ferrées en haute-marne à bourbonne les
bains la décrue est amorcée mais cela ne
suffit pas à remonter le moral des
habitants dans cet hôtel tout est à
reconstruire
ou presque
on a travaillé une année puis 11 yves
hayez tout tout tout d'un seul coup est
parti et puis mais bon faut avoir du
courage et puisse dire on va repartir et
puis voilà ailleurs le découragement
cède à la colère en quatre fois dessus
de la terre line adam dit qu'une fois et
encore en perdre en plein plein de
choses parce que elle a vécu ce t il ya
tout ce qu'on veut donc c'est si
catastrophique life un fléau peut en
cacher un autre
l'eau s'est retirée et c'est désormais
le verglas qui menace de couvrir les
routes de l'est